[Music]
let's dude this is the first time we got
the angle for Alton Walker here man what
do you need law for what do you got
clicking on software is it doesn't work
with my song ride update my software but
what would you use it for oh yeah well I
mean you know sometimes you can just
outsource it you know you have to pay
for their pilot you know that's Cox
media so they don't probably cut the
check they both coin right here they
made you know ws beating on all those
cameras in I know it [__] me is I know
that's the starship you're getting in
there that's why we time this out what
did man this interview is right on time
I'm in that man's you are you you're
like you're there you've put in all the
work and now you're starting to see some
returns trickle in at this moment but
it's gonna be a flood soon man we got
speaking of flood we have fonta swatters
ear for you that's all you my dog hot
breath I always be thinking I'm told I
hope you put it miss before you did that
no doubt because it's you hear it you're
hot brethren yeah yeah yeah yeah my wife
hates it that's why I do it every
episode I can feel it over how does it
feel - now you listen but now you're our
man this is man this is this is huge man
yeah yeah how breath it's gonna be some
big man it's already big like amongst
comedians comedians know about this yeah
but dude man you you have room to really
take this thing to another like to
another level what do you see for us I
mean just I mean you did you already did
Montreal you did I mean they should be
paying you now I mean yeah don't be so I
mean sooner later people say and then
you know people gonna be paying you to
get on the show you know nope yeah
exactly are we gonna be calling hey man
I got to push this movie man I need to
get on but not this did I ever seen
anything like it so but that's why I
like you is because you've been able to
create a living like your way not really
relying on anyone else it's oh no you
found a way to build a brand and really
monetize it yeah yeah yeah it takes work
though it takes work I mean you know
when I quit my job three and a half
years ago what was that job I was
working at Clayton State University I
was a mission rep so when I graduated
college I was I had a bachelor's in well
I have a bachelors in mass communication
okay I'm not dealing radio video audio
all day I could do all that voiceovers
edit videos I do it well but I started
working in the missions because I didn't
have a job when I graduated college I
worked at Payne and emissions then I
moved over to Clayton State and I was
just working in the missions man getting
students in school and what we would do
is like to get to a high school we had
to send out emails we sent a email
blasts to a bunch of teachers or a bunch
of college high school counselors asking
can we come in and talk to these
students so that's what we did and we
did college we did college fairs we set
up a table right all that stuff like
that's what we did and so I took that's
those same skills and applied to myself
so I sent out emails like all day man oh
yeah we talked about oh yeah we did it
like I feel like cuz we've talked after
shows and I feel like you're just
bubbling with insight for comics
that you haven't been able to share so
that's what this is about
oh yeah and it all out I don't mind and
I don't mind because a lot of committees
not gonna do it
that's see that's what I give people
withhold information I'm like you can
give them the sauce but they gotta cook
it they gotta cook it now I do
eventually I'm gonna charge you knows
I'm like if anybody want information you
better get it out of me now while I'm in
this just free give it out but that's
why we're here I've noticed like the
information that we sat down the targets
we'll talk about it today but the
information I've gave it to at least
five to ten other comedians have they
done it no yep because it takes it takes
work man to do that part of comedy like
the administration part you know I
I'm tired of comedian like okay I
started doing comedy I was doing
churches nothing but churches five years
in the game in churches then some
totally started doing clubs and I
started doing clubs and I saw why the
funniest comedians aren't working you
gotta you gotta have if you don't have a
booking agent or some kind of booking
manager somebody that's going out to get
the book is for you how are you getting
booked and I guess they think just going
around town and getting on stages but
you can't get booked but how long is
that gonna work I mean so it takes it's
administration part that I don't get
like specially full-time comedians if
you what do you do during the day do you
just play video games and chill and lay
down and then go out on the stage at
night is that what you think this comedy
business is about and it's not so I told
comedians in our follow up
did you do it yeah one day but man you
know alright stop complaining about
getting booked there boom so let's get
into it let's get into the
administrative work oh yeah so I don't
feel like one and we can do one at a
time no so I know you got a couple
different streams oh so I feel like this
when I worked at Clayton State I had to
be in my office at 8:00 I got off at 5
o'clock you know luckily I was a
recruiter so sometimes I didn't have to
go into you know if I went to school I'd
probably go home and something like that
but usually you work 9:00 to 5:00 job
from 9:00 to 5:00 is like I see so many
people who are entrepreneurs they give
all this energy and their life to a job
for nine to five and they give all day
like give it all to him and complain I'm
doing all this for this company man
hello give me a raise blah then they
jump off their job and it's like what
are you doing from 9:00 to 5:00 you
sleep in two would win so I treat my
comedy like a nine-to-five I wake up
every morning I'm at my desk well now
I'm mad I'm on the morning show so I
have to be up at 3:30 every morning from
show start at 5:00 like sometimes I can
get up at 4:00 and still make it cuz I
have to have my segment I write my
segment I have to be at this station at
least by 4:30 before five o'clock
because my segment is the first segment
that they do it started come on at 5:10
well earlier than that we have to do a
teaser so I have to be up there I go
home I may take a quick look that then I
wake up and I start my my job I get on
the computer and start looking you know
I'm saying so but before I was doing
that I will wake up at 8 o'clock get
dressed
be at my desk at 9 o'clock and when I
get off at 5:00 see you don't for myself
and you treat it you may do like a lunch
break but you try doing it sometimes I
don't sometimes I you know if you review
working home you know the kitchen right
there you just pinkies up and get back
to work
so I don't really take lunch breaks like
that but I what I'm saying that I
treated it as if I was working at
Clayton State University yeah I'm giving
myself the same amount of energy I gave
those people and I get tired of people
not putting that energy that they gave
someone else and to themselves I don't I
don't get it that's the thing with like
we're just keeping it comedy based it's
like being a full-time comedian and
you're at home it's like you have the
freedom to do whatever you want but also
you have the freedom to whatever you
shouldn't write I have trouble because
you know I'm full-time working from home
and I have trouble staying focused or
like committing an entire day like I
mean I maybe some days you know I do
other days it's like an hour and then I
get like a TD or whatever like I do how
do you keep yourself within that
structure of the day I gotta pay these
bills so it's just but needs-based I
have to pay and it's like I get it for a
job right I did it for a company I gave
them I was on
yeah me too yeah everyday yeah yeah I
wasn't missing so it's like I don't why
not do it for yourself and and sometimes
you have to UM you know sometimes I find
myself if I do that I'll I used to leave
the house and maybe go to Starbucks like
get out the house and go work in another
environment if you're getting kind of
like oh okay I'm getting lazy you know
I'm saying but most the time and if you
have your setup you have your desk don't
sit on your couch yeah don't be relaxed
you know get a desk get a workspace and
get fully dressed take a shower but like
you're going on a job and you sit at
that desk and get to work do you
structure your days like okay today I'm
doing the email bookings today I'm
working on mice because you do a lot of
workshops - yeah it's like today I'm
working on my workshops like do you
commit certain tasks to each day yeah I
mean you have to because I'm and I'd be
on like lately my comedy has been taking
off but in my workshops last workshop
I've done we did a comments fair but the
last workshop I think was in September
and that's because I haven't been
booking it I haven't been sending out
emails to colleges and schools I've been
sending my comedy emails out and they
were coming in but the booking part for
the the workshops have declined because
I haven't been focusing on it so I
noticed when I don't focus on something
so you say that I'm right yeah
starting in January I have to do another
RIBA like another marketing reboot for
the next in line Network which is my
company that do workshop because my
workshops decline and the booking of
them because I nobody knows about it
there you know about it through social
media but when I send out emails or get
in my car and stop by high school stop
by a college and get in front of their
faces like look this is what I have I
get book that people book you when you
send out emails you'll be surprised well
let's get into that part because you
mentioned I'll sit down treat like a job
and then do my booking emails but you
have a whole system behind I got a whole
system man let's spill it so first of
all man there's this yes there's this
he's so excited
there's this add-on if you especially if
you have a Mac and I'll know how I work
on any other PC or whatever any other
thing it was not a Mac computer I'm
really being a Mac but so there's this
add-on called Google extract email or
Google email extractor it allows you to
pull all the emails with within a
website so say if you go to this is go
to any website like I always go to like
a college and they have all these staff
members under that directory it's like
600 people now you can go one by one
what I used to do I just go one by one
and take each email and put it in Excel
I used to like it used to take me
forever
there's to every email but that's and
taking and putting the exhale so I could
have my you know database database yeah
so um but you could download that that
way you can pull emails I throw them in
Excel and I send out an email blast once
a week or twice a week sometimes I said
all over 2,000 emails a week geez and
it's in his code email these are people
that I don't know never met them but
these are emails like today I sit down
8,500 because I have a database of a
over 8,500 emails so those people I sent
again but and it's through like this
third party called Miller Lite mail it's
almost like nil check MailChimp okay
yeah so if I sent you an email already
you go into my MailChimp cuz you're
gonna get a monthly email and then you
could not subscribe yourself and so you
don't subscribe you're gonna get an
email from me every month saying that
hey I'm doing this book blah blah blah
so yeah today I literally send out 8,500
emails but it's the blast just a blast
and then I found out with that but
Marilyn like some of its going to spam
so I'm looking at my list and there's
people that never opened up my email so
now I decided to take those emails put
it in my actual email BCC blind copy and
make sure they're getting they're
getting it because they haven't even
opened it man not as people that opened
it 20 times but it's
people that never opened it at all
because it's going today spam so what
let's let's get in the weeds here so
first off what is like the title of the
email it depends on what you trying to
do like today was bring laughter to your
holiday then them you know but I started
sending this email in October because
the holidays are coming up now when it
get close to the new year is gonna say a
happy new year blah blah brain comma to
your new year start your new year with
laughter blah blah blah with comedian
Alton Walker and then the email to
change up the design to change up stuff
like that but that's for the email
blasts I send another email out through
Microsoft Word and is typed out because
I'm finding out people this probably a
lot going on people like I heard they
know that's why we're doing this cuz
there's so much that you just pours out
of you so I wanted to be sure to like
caps yes I bring it all together but
it's all losing sense though
yeah okay it's or emails I'm confusing
yeah it's all it's just a lot of good
invention so it's two type of emails the
Miller Lite but then I also send the
email out through Microsoft Word which
you can send out through mail merger
okay like you could type an email out
through Microsoft and mail merge it into
your actual email account and then send
out an email blast to Microsoft and mail
merger is an app it's it's in Microsoft
it's a Microsoft Word if you go if you
go to tools in Microsoft you go down
you'll see mail merger and if you have
Outlook or whatever that's on your
that's connected to your email to send
an email blast through Microsoft by
pulling the emails from your excel file
so you can download your excel file up
too just like you do Miller Lite or
MailChimp but you got that you can
upload it to Microsoft Word and then
it's an email blast house like that the
reason why I do that because people read
they like the people read the email
before they look at a nice designed
email that feel like you're selling
something so that's what mailer light is
is like a design team a little I feel
like if you look at it feel like you're
selling something
hey it's big it's nice it's nicely
decorated but when people look at it
most time when you look at stuff like
that what you do oh you don't even read
it right you know you just move on
because it feel like somebody's trying
to sell you something so that that the
mailer light unless let's compare them
so the mailer light is like a designed
email like it'll have a picture of you
but yeah buttons you can stretch this
yeah okay and video but it's embedded in
there you know I'm saying so like say it
feel like it felt like yeah he wants
something he's but if I I noticed when I
type it out and say hey how you doing my
name is chameleon Alton Walker just
saying if you want to add comedic comedy
to your event blah blah blah they
actually read it you know because I
guess they feel like it's okay this is
really a conversation this you know who
did it to them yeah so I said that one
first that's the one I sent out first
that's my initial contact with people is
the typed out email once I said that
then I move you over to Miller Lite so
you can be part of the monthly blast
okay
yeah and that the mail merger it merges
like your 8500 emails in Excel yeah so
lose a word yeah so if you said you're
like today you're deciding to go to so
for instance I do churches right so I
will go to a church website or I find a
website they have a list of a bunch of
churches I go to that website and I go
to action to that church website and
I'll pull all the emails that of the
staff at that church from the add-on
right from that also what's that on
cardigan it's called Google email
extractor perfect so the church may have
okay I got the church and then they have
staff and then they'll pull up their
staff and they have all their emails on
this one page and over in the corner you
can press this button and it pulls
everybody much email you just highlight
it throw their junk in Excel that may be
like 50 emails you go to another church
do the same thing that's another 50 go
to they may have a hundred people on
staff so I get up to about 500 to 700
emails and I already been through maybe
20 to 30 churches and I collected all
these emails and I'm about to get ready
to contact 30 churches or about six to
seven
emails and bam that's my blast one click
of a button put it in click and it goes
everybody what is your success rate what
is like the return on that's the thing I
have to monitor because I have it but I
can feel it you can feel that people are
responding and sometimes you get people
like I had a lady in October she said it
was a church in Tennessee she's like we
got your email last year but we didn't
have anything for you so now we're
deciding we have a comma so can you come
in how much you charge boom so let's say
you send out you say get from monitor
this but maybe this will spark some sort
of insight is that you say you have
let's say you send a hundred emails how
many typically respond and then how many
convert I would say I mean like say I
don't have the exact number I would say
if you sent out a hundred emails you may
get 10 respond yeah maybe 20 sometimes
but like they may come you may get 5 to
10 that comes directly like that quick
and then you may get someone to never
respond but respond two or three months
later mm-hmm
you know I'm saying but the fact you got
to keep sending the hema that's why I
put him in mellow light cuz you got to
keep getting email until you say no or
unsubscribe listen no it's not look cuz
a lot of people think because the
president answered that means no no it
doesn't mean that it just mean they
didn't answer you got to tell me no and
I've had now I have some people say can
you please get me off your email blasts
how happy would have done that and can
you not email at us anymore okay all
right well how did you get my email is
on the website why are you asking me how
did I get your email when your email is
on your site yeah you put your email on
the site for people to contact you so
emails were emails were emails work and
I got it really before before I was
doing it well this is after cuz Kevin
Hart even talks about emails in his book
but I was already doing emails I already
sent emails out but he tells us the
importance of emails like after a show
collect emails if you do a tour you
should be connecting emails if you're
doing
the circuit headlining comedy clubs you
should collect emails because those
people you gonna be coming back next
year
mm-hmm so if I got your email and you're
in Atlanta I got all these emails that I
come to Lana and I titled that email
that excel file Atlanta people I came to
every time I come to Atlanta I get so
when I come back I send you email blasts
hey y'all coming back to Atlanta click
here to get your tickets if they had a
good time last year they're gonna come
back this year
see I'm saying yeah yeah so why are we
collected emails I think sometimes we
just people give us the knowledge and we
just look over it we don't pay attention
yeah it's all timing too you can hear
something 10 times but it may take that
tenth time for it to actually register
with it man sometimes they still don't
rich and sometimes it doesn't nice yeah
yeah but some I'm sorry we have some
comedians or someone too lazy is
entitled like profession in the world
cuz I mean yeah we get up and we talk on
a mic but we're someone too late
especially when you come to the business
side hmm that's sometime when it comes
to the right inside you know some coming
even if you don't write on piece of
paper or we're still gets sometimes we
get lazy when it comes to producing
content yes no but we're lazy man
somebody's weird some of the laziest
people when it comes to to business and
profession well that's the goal of this
is to maybe help at least inspire some
people or not be like oh so how do you
how do you collect emails is it do you
have like an app or do you just get them
to write it down or um if I do shows I
will I will collect like if I do a
church show or something like that
sometimes I will try to collect emails
when I'm getting more into that because
of the Kevin Hart book but the way I get
my emails is from I literally sit at my
desk and good life if it's Church this
day there may be college so when one
week I went through all because I still
do Christian comedy and stuff like that
and one week I remember going through
all the Christian colleges like all
colleges that has critters like 100 of
them went to every website every cops
website it pulled up their chaplain
and pull up their their supervisor or
campus life supervisor grab the email
its enemy mailman so how do you how do
you name your price do you calculate
because that's something comedians also
struggle with is one knowing their Worth
and also even how to even calculate what
your price shall be well I'm going to
put it out there listen if you don't
know your price range and you're
struggling with it the easiest thing you
can do is ask that's asked the budget
okay what is the intended budget okay
that's all you got to do listen if they
email you hey how much you charge or I
want to book you hey thank you for
contacting me
what is your attend the budget for your
event easy boom and then that will tell
you that some people y'all are under I'm
gonna give you example so I'm on gig
salad which I don't like gig salad no
more I mean I really don't I'm not a fan
of gets outed cuz people who were low
but I've been getting undercut by other
comedians and I had a car worn out I
won't put a name out so this show was in
the New Year it was like January 6 now
if you're comedian you know you don't
get no gigs that first week in January
sometimes January is super slow now but
the first week in January
it's like December the lady hits me up
to gig salad I want you on January 6 I
said hey what's your budget it's 15
minutes for $500 15 minutes 500 I'm
gonna take that right it's December I
think it was like December 20th there's
bout to be new it was like two weeks it
man I'm gonna take that 15 minutes in
Atlanta I'm home
yes I'm gonna take 15 minutes to find a
dog easy money um but I'd send her if
you know gigs and I send her the quote
she asks for the quote I heard presented
to her and then she comes back I mean
this is like 30 minutes oh yeah we uh we
found a comedian that said he's gonna do
it half your price
and I said okay well because I'm at a
point now I'm like the Lord's I will go
it's for I'll go 400 but I'm not going
I'm not gonna do that because of help
mm-hmm and I shouldn't even did that
because she really wanted me in the
first place she ended up booking me
because she wanted me she was just
trying to play that game
I found so I'm like I gotta figure out
who this comedian is so one day this
dude come to my house and I'm sharing
the story I'm like man there's gigs out
of somebody undercutting me man by a
roadblock they don't even know man the
gig was 500 ollie
he was like for real like that was me
I said you idiot I said do you were
about to do it for 250 when she had $500
on the table but you trying to get a gig
so bad you'd even ask for the budget I
said I I not told her she still went
after me went for me and I charged a 400
hours still got Magoo you know but I'm
like dude if you don't know your price
just ask for the budget you're
undercutting your savings sometimes i
undercutting myself sometimes the budget
was way more than I asked for but there
was my oh that's it okay well then we
give you that yeah it's asking is a
great little hack into getting the most
out of your how much what is your
intended budget for this event that's a
great question because you may charge
200 and they may have a three thousand
dollar budget right and you think they
don't say oh no we'll give you 3,000 I
don't say 200 oh okay
no one's you may get everyone's well
somebody say well we we want to give you
more but how many people gonna say yeah
well we saved a lot of money also know
your value if you are getting undercut
you can tell the Booker it's like yeah I
mean you can get a curio or you know you
can get a guaranteed safety like Delvaux
that if it crashes you won't blow up do
you think you know what I mean
hopefully it just don't mess us up
especially when like I said when I was
doing churches all events to the kyrios
out there either do your thing I mean I
mean I mean this be honest you first
started doing if you just get
it's a comedy of course you're not gonna
be making big bucks right you're you're
trying to build your audience and build
your material but I would still suggest
ask for the budget I don't have you been
doing it for a month if you don't know
about the money you don't but if you get
somebody to come and say hey how much
you charge X for the budget stop
undercutting yourself ax for people
budget people get out I know my good
friend marvel hunter always say get out
of people other people's pocket he's
been down here yeah you don't know what
they have and if you don't know how much
you charge X for the budget another
thing you do is you'll hustle through
Eventbrite also oh yeah Eventbrite I
haven't done it in a while because I've
been on other websites but Eventbrite is
another place you can grab events it's a
place full of events so for instance one
one time I went on Eventbrite I have a
bit about marriage so the way I do my
mic clip so when I send out videos and
stuff like that I don't send out a
20-minute video I don't send out a 30
minute video I break my videos down into
topics and segments and stuff like that
so I have a bit about marriage that I
created so I went to Eventbrite and
typed in a search engine marriage and
all these events about marriage came up
bridal shows everything I'm in and I
went to every single it was probably
like 30 pages of events because you can
you know you can search the region on
Eventbrite so you can pull it out like
you can search this Georgia but on that
map you can pull it out and search South
East region and it'll give you all the
events within those states and that map
so it was like 30 pages of events from
from its in those states like Alabama
Georgia Florida you know in the
surrounding states and I just started
sending out emails to those events this
lady hit me up about about a bridal show
she wanted me to host a brighter felt
and it was like two weeks to through
it's out it was $1,500 gig
she didn't know about me I reached out
to her and she's she was like oh I
didn't think about a comedian or host a
comedian host for my event and I end up
doing that writer so for that for that
amount
sir are you messaging them directly on
Eventbrite you can you can down you can
do it directly through Eventbrite or if
you go to Eventbrite sometimes you'll
see that they put email in in the and
the words in the description okay you'll
see email or you'll see a website of the
company or the organization you can just
go to their website and pull the email
from their website and what does the
email say the same thing hey my name is
Alton Walker just wanted to know if you
want to add comedy to your event here's
my here's my website my reviews and
here's my link so if for instance it's
some about marriage the marriage bids
gonna be the first video link that I put
on there if it's a church then I put
something about church that's the firmly
if it's a college I may have a bit about
going to school or being in college you
know the struggles of college that'll be
my first video so that way when they
click it oh he has material for my
audience you know and so when they look
it up oh man you know I've got this
marriage retreat this is perfect he's
talking about marriage his own saying
tell you having the clips tailored to
the target target is oh I got that from
Jude I've said you can you could tell
you know something once and I got it
okay
dude a cockatoo named his manager
knocking Tunde his manager told me about
emailing okay he said at one time he's
like yeah we email we do cold emails and
cold calls they actually call people
they pick up their phone and I had
someone doing it which I'm gonna go back
to it I might hire an assistant they
they actually pick up the phone and say
hey my name is such a--such we have a
comedian we're gonna know who's over
your events blah blah blah I could send
them over hey you got a comedian wanted
to know if you want to come by or do
such-and-such so they actually pick up
that phone and they get booked I haven't
got to the phone part but I can do the
emails all day but we did do phone we
were doing phone we did it for a week
and we had such a great response
Oh awesome response from picking to the
phone and talking about housing Walker
coming into your company or your church
did you have a script or anything no
it's just I had a friend of mine call
and he picked up the phone hey who's
over your who coordinates your events
who's over your events they sent them
over hey this is such a such such such I
am representing comedian Allison Walker
just want to know if y'all have any
events where you need a comedian to come
in by blah and sometimes we got uh I
think I booked that week maybe two gigs
because that was my oh yeah we actually
have such a such coming up let me see if
my pastor or my such-and-such is want
you to come by can you can we get your
email blah blah and it's like that you
know and then you just some you just do
like a percentage for the that would
almost be like a booking agent I guess
oh well if you look for me I give
presented yeah at the time I didn't have
a booking manager so is about my friend
of my your friend would get a place for
if he booked it if he got it he got a
person okay yeah yeah that's what I was
saying yeah yeah all day all day but so
so I can tune they told me about that
and then I talked to another comedian
Vetter comedian he was talking about
Marcus D Wiley probably he's a comedian
he's on the gospel side straight gospel
and he the one told me about doing
comedy that that's geared towards your
target audience yeah yeah winner right
there I'm saying so after you told me
that I need least art expanding my
marriage my thoughts on marriage you
know I'm saying I that now it's like a
25-minute bit mm-hmm just on marriage
just relationship in marriage it's like
25 to 30 minutes so if I go to a retreat
I could do thirty minutes on just
relationships and you'll but the clip
you send may only be a couple minutes
like a couple of minutes maybe four
minutes but got one bit about marriage
and my thought is very funny and I send
them that and they're like and that's
marriage is one topic so they're look at
worse I have a marriage retreat I'm
gonna have matter of fact just did a
marriage you're cheating make it so I
have this mayor's retreat or I have this
marriage conference so there's Bridal
whatever and I have this odd as these
couples he's perfect
I need some entertainment and he's
talking about marriage oh that's perfect
I could see also what would um we did it
we did a type 5 podcast and after after
one chokes I've been a fan of yours and
just your ability to also connect with
your audience and to the show because a
lot of times comedians are like well it
did my show you know you know and then I
just stayed in the green room or
whatever it's but you you get out and
touch the people and talk to people
marry the value of that and you you I've
got a lot of gigs them not even hitting
the stage sometimes sometime he was just
talking to people and then they ask you
what you do mm-hmm
you know and I believe in this is real
this is cliches but his network is your
network we say it all the time people
throw it away our network is your
network the more people you know the
more money you make the more and they
got this thing called it's not about who
you know it's not about what you know I
know you heard about oh it's about who
you know it's about what you know you
never heard that before I've heard it's
like it's not I think it's the hand you
shake yeah but it's not even it so I
always say it's not about who you know
it's not about what you know but it's
about who knows you so it's a difference
like we know a lot of people but if they
don't know you know what you do how can
I book you how can I use you so you
going out and wearing hot breath or
wearing a shirt that says funny to me
that's what I started wearing things
that says that I'm a comedian you know I
got a shirt that say I played too much
so when I'm out people look at my shirt
and say oh yeah he's got to be funny
he's got to be blah blah what'd you do
man and I get it all the time yeah I
like your shirt are you a comedian yeah
what can I come check you out it
oh man I'm either a tail karma Theodore
here or here's my car do you need you
know the book you got a card yeah I got
cards okay you know you could book me or
follow me on social media you know but
networking how many times you got a gig
for somebody just calling you and said
hey somebody told me about you yeah you
know oh you did this it's about talking
is about shaking hands and and that's
why after every show I don't care where
I'm at I'm at that door shaking hands
when people walk out I've seen you every
time hey hey girl what's going on get up
Hey
and that kind of data some time that is
sealed a deal
like you was funny on stage but now I
like you as a person right so I want to
book you I wanna you know and in Atlanta
commentator's people been following me
on social media on Facebook
hey I seen you at a a tail comic theater
you were hilarious and in the fact that
I'm clean you know you know they're like
oh man my mom birthday coming up for my
church is having this or you know I get
a lot of more clean shows because I
listen to your homecoming I hate having
you didn't cuss one time yeah so my mom
can listen to you and that's how you get
you get booked so what in got a few more
minutes here what is the a couple of
your streams are like hosting events you
also do workshops stand up as well what
are some of your other streams those the
main things my my workshop and my
standup I also got I do a segment on
kiss 104 I have a contract with them I
do that every morning and we do some
work just word of mouth to like oh they
saw you somewhere
well it came through social media okay
sue man Miller saw a bit of saw me doing
my Deacon Quattlebaum saying would I put
the fat fro and I was singing and he was
like I want to bring that however that
thing you doing on social media to kiss
104 now we're supposed to go to somebody
else
hang on bring our names up as far as
goes somebody else but they were so
concerned about contract and this and
this and that and I was like yo I'd do
it for free
oh okay and I ain't telling that but it
was known that I do it for free like so
from November to like June I was
throwing them segments and I didn't have
to do it as much but I throw like once a
week or two or three a month and I just
record a segment and send it to him at
some time like they have a topic there
like a make you do someone a Super Bowl
Bible about said that John to him like
in 30 minutes they're like oh man his
production a song and everything within
the production so I did it for a couple
of months for free and then I get a
phone call hey man
the the was was the program director
wants information he wants to
put some money in your pocket and so I'm
like cool save the contract I didn't
like the contract so I had to send the
back to him that's a whole nother topic
about reading contracts because they
wanted to own my my material and I'm
like can't sign that
but they still like I still just got my
pay they started paying me man and I get
a monthly check for doing comedy you
know doing a seven from networking zoo
man I knew him as a comedian and then I
would put in content on social media and
that content fit their audience because
kiss 104 their audience is black women
that go to church uh-huh so I do a
prayer every morning
that's hilarious and they love it yeah
and for all these events actually
contracts her a good thing to touch on
cuz I had an OG actually send me a
contract template yeah he's been he's
someone sent him and he's been using for
years like for all of these shows you're
doing do you have a contract you're
sending them first
I'd say my contract I'll you know III do
have a contract template but when you
start getting into licensing and
industry stuff you have to pay attention
to your contract because there's some
words in there that would throw you off
now and I love the company I work I love
Cox media and all that but like said in
that contract it was saying that if I
would have signed it they would have
been able to shop my segments to other
companies with other stations within
their company and man I probably
probably woulda got paid for right
because I was signing Cox media you know
you know let it own your own my stuff so
I had to be like I don't I don't want
y'all to own it because it's still mine
like y'all asked me to give it to you
like right this is still mine I don't
want you to have only now you have
exclusive rights in Georgia and I won't
go to another radio station here in
Georgia but in California and others
yeah my segments can be syndicated you
know and it could be syndicated within
your company so I don't want I want to
just make sure I'm good I love things
and I love like Cox meters one of the
dopest I mean they're huge they they're
like yes
good company by Cox beef I know he's
covering his bases now I love Cox I love
gosh but but understand like you got to
understand business and they understood
business you know I'm saying and what
was what was crazy about the person that
gave me the contract looked at he said
oh I didn't see that I was just sending
you a contract okay this is the wrong
contract for this boom yeah yeah so I
had nothing today was just doing there
he was just trying to do their job but
that contract that means you own my
character like I can't give you the
character worlds whatever you were doing
the administrative work right I can at
the constant rain : everyone there and
say okay yeah that right there is gonna
be a problem because if I give you out
my character once we've done what do I
do I can I not use the character no more
yeah hone it so there any other the same
thing for series exhale I all mine too
yeah I just got on series exhale but I
own that copyright to my material I own
it how'd you do that that's the one you
don't want to share but a lot of
comedians date they record you know
whoever record your your set is gonna
own your copyright you know saying
that's how sometimes working something
the copyright on SiriusXM they get half
of your royalties okay but I all mine
you know we got it where I got to record
it we set it up I broke it down into
tracks
audio tracks my bitching on and
submitted it I and we got some got some
connections submitted it and I'm the
performer and I own my own copyright all
right we'll talk I'll send you an email
all Santas get to the business this Matt
Ben I hope this wasn't boring or
whatever calm down you killed it buddy
okay cuz boy held it but I'm trying to I
got I just want people to make money in
what we do and there's so much money out
there to make either you can get it
through social media now social media is
winning if you can get a million
followers you can sell out shows at a
comedy club that's the best way that's a
great way to go I don't have a million
father I have about in between Facebook
and mr.
probably got 30,000 followers maybe most
people don't have a million [__] yeah so
if you got a million father I know
comedians that I've put on stage for the
first time they going home with $11,000
on the weekend and they just started
coming only been doing comedy for 10
months I know what could mean I only
been doing comments with 10 months got a
beginning 11 but she settled out UK head
on it and that social media takes work
man that's a job content to create
content like that man come on we do
social media it ain't that easy to get
1.5 million follow mm-hmm 2 million
followers creating content man that
takes work and and I applaud them for
doing what they do so if you're not
gonna create content then send out
emails do something man thing don't just
sit there and then complain man this
Carmel butter I'm doing I just gave you
what you can do boom to make money every
now you can sit there and complain or
you get this money so before we get out
of here
is there anything else you want the
world to know I'm open like I said I'm
I'm open book man you know me I'm always
forgiving information except as I'm
Sirius XM thing we're working on turning
it to it I would definitely talk to you
get off I tell you what what we got
going on to get did that make that so so
where can the other people they do want
to book you or follow you yeah follow me
out some walkers show across the board
Facebook Twitter Instagram
Alton Walker like save you a comedian
man hey hit me up young comedians I'm
always open I'm always at the clubs I'm
tagging people I'm giving people advice
but at the end of the day a lot of
people don't use it so that's why I just
keep giving it out cuz you got to use it
you got to put into practice you know
and there's money out here for everybody
there's so many people's money out for
the people willing to do the work the
people that's willing to do work if you
notice comedians that are successful are
the comedian's that put in work you have
to put in work and it's more than I'm
not talking I was just hitting stages
yeah I'm getting on these stages man
there's more to it it's a business
Oh business this shows a job the
business yeah so you wonder well he's
not funny man while you get booked he
got his business right sure
well I hope if anything the listeners
will leave here with their business
right and it's not gonna be overnight
like yeah it's gonna be a learning curve
and your emails will get better and
you'll get more efficient so gonna have
a website linked you got I don't got a
dope website your website's a must it's
it's almost like a billboard
yep social media but a website adds
legitimacy to what I'm doing right so
you got to have all that in place for
you guys have you just started what I'm
telling you your pot okay news you gotta
have a product to sell air Zach you know
like I didn't start trying to sell
myself to literally probably like seven
years in the game when I was like oh I
have a quality product I saw you just
did a podcast workshop yeah doing
podcast workshops yeah yeah okay yeah
and there's even more ways your time out
I have an eight week comedy class here
like you could break that down into
workshops yeah each week could be its
own work each week yeah this is oh you
got so much information man I said you
can create a website and it's a John my
next in line Network
it's a drop-down of I think I got 15
workshops that I do
mm-hm you know then colleges make its a
budget out there for it man boom and you
just gotta send that email out man
or get in your car and sit down in front
of their face and say I have a podcast
workshop I see you have a mass
communication program here I want to see
if you want to bah bah bah bah bah and
they may bring you all right my man so
get this money man is is right man you
got to get the business right Alton
Walker my man thanks for being on hop
right there thank you man like sad I
hope that was good you know all that man
you know like sometimes this this part
can be a headache and can be a little
bit you know dull but this part oh the
jockey this work just the information
you'd be like ah man is so much yeah
well that's why I mean people people
definitely wanna listen to this a couple
times yeah definitely take notes on this
this yeah yeah this is one this was a
master class on how you can actually
turn your jokes into
profit money chokes it's it I was trying
to think of a J word they like jokes
into notes money notes and they genero
cuz it's done there Gennaro you can't
say Gennaro cuz that's turn your jokes
and what's another word guys for money
that start with a Jedi like that
workshop man jokes and uh I'll give you
a finder's because I'm gonna because I'm
my plan is what I just told you I'm
gonna put it in the workshop because in
the workshop you would know exactly how
to do it like I just told you but you
still know you gotta India workshops
more intimate to connect I can I could
show you what to download and all that
so I I'm they're actually trying to do
put do a workshop all right we got it
first so hot breath send them emails out
me man let's do it
already thanks green man hot breath well
that's why you got the water man for you
[Music]